welcome to this video i just started
this recording and someone started to
drill in the neighboring neighboring
apartment what the heck i hope it's not
a steady feature of this video let's see
okay going to play the room and actually
you see levin decided what i should do a
move nine but okay he went for deform
not even going 483 i am playing this
line against that i 94 actually it's
what I normally play first yeah but okay
it's mostly mostly um just a
transposition yeah this is a funny funny
line or interesting that's kind of
uncommon normally white argues that you
shouldn't trade pieces in this kind of
position because white has more space
but he's happily trading pieces okay
well that that's all very good for me
actually no problems here I've been only
structure with them pieces traded and
now I even get to take on f3 that looks
really nice
I am spending a bit of time on 92 and
bishops III would have helped here this
is already looking very problematic okay
so i can put a note on f4 or some night
g6 no it's also really good but let's
see what is his plan actually can go a
form maybe but ok I'm going to put this
here first simply completely blocking
the position what is his plan I wonder I
don't get a look on the summer on the
Kings side would be nice yeah look on
age six would be checkmate almost but
hard too hard to see how to get that
maybe I can do something different and
play a five before I've got the next
report on the queenside so this is maybe
not a bad some idea also okay and also I
have the possibility to just so that's
nice okay wow so I'm he's given me the
key Queen side is closed i think i've
got a protected person the only thing
that I need to do now is trade rooks and
it's it's gone it's there a way to do
that hmm i can go h5 and maybe then rook
i can actually put this on e 7 and then
swing the rooks over
if I go King g7 am I go king g seven
lucky seven lucky aid I don't I don't
see white surviving this with the g file
open now that's not possible to survive
I can I can ignore the threat on the
apes other g7 porn ok Wow
Wow
one shown 926 is like a provisional
account or something no yeah after Luke
h8s it's it's it's made on h2 right now
we see how is he avoiding that white
resigns whoa okay i hope the drilling is
not it's not continuing yeah okay here
here yeah I'd hear what normally goes b3
I think if i'm not mistaken or not how
do you play that with wide you can also
start with h 3 i'm not i'm not sure but
i don't think i'm sorry about that
nothing i can do this this trading is
this really something that helps me a
lot yeah because in this kind of benoni
structure I quite often um the the
Benoni side here has too many pieces
yeah you're you're lacking some space
and here i'm getting the bishop on g4
traded and now i also get to the f6
diagonal in a very comfortable way if he
goes here i already have this
opportunity coming it's destroying his
pawn structure yeah and here we had
essentially the same thing with them the
bishops traded hmm actually this was
more precise and then queen f6 after
this he could have played Queen d3 which
is not as disastrous I mean this is
still pretty nice for me but it's not
okay it is pretty disastrous actually
you can get at ng5 yeah that's almost a
lost endgame even if the computer is not
agreeing it's just giving minus 0.6 but
this is a disaster here with
with this bishop they get a complete
dark square blockade can just enter King
with King to e5 and I've got three
against two here where that sets it's
almost a win yeah and this is this is
also not much fun okay yeah I really
didn't expect him to close close things
here and now yeah now it's very
comfortable you can play with f5 rookie
fade my idea was to get the King to e7
and then play age five rook edge a Droog
h6 root g six but he is it just took
here and yeah that that's it's just this
fantastic black the only way to to not
lose immediately as probably to go back
and then I've got h4 h5 coming something
something like that but he has to give
up the exchange this kind of this kind
of thing yeah I mean this is not going
to go into horde the NT is here is just
made on edge to unavoidable really
computer showing it made already know
minus twenty-eight my minus-30 minus-40
def means that he is close to finding
some some kind of mate yeah okay thanks
for watching